The Victorians had a word for it, knew we that hollow ache that gnawed at the bones of the idle
rich. Too much time, too many distractions, and yet nothing to fill the void. They traveled the
globe, amassed libraries of curiosities, threw parties that would make a modern influencer weep
with envy, and still the emptiness remained. We've just made it worse. Now, a Nui isn't a curse
reserved for dukes and duchesses. It's a mass-produced condition delivered straight to your palm.
Your phone holds more music than a royal concert hall, more films than a lifetime of cinemas,
more books than a scholar's dream. And yet here you are, staring at a grid of icons, fingers hovering,
heart-heavy, not because there's nothing to do, because there's too much. This is the paradox of
the digital buffet. When everything is available, nothing feels worth choosing. Your brain,
once starved for stimulation, now drowns in it. You've trained yourself to crave the next hit,
the next scroll, the next flicker of light on the screen. And in the end, you're left with the
same hollow feeling the aristocrats knew so well, only now. It's wrapped in silicon and sold as
entertainment. Let's call it app-based boredom. The ritual begins with the app-switching dance,
30 seconds on Instagram just enough to see a curated life you'll never live. A swipe to X,
where the world's arguments play out in real time, none of them yours to settle. A dive into Reddit,
where the endless threads of human misery and triviality blur into one great numbing home.
Your brain never settles. It never lingers. It's always moving, always searching, always just one tap
away from the next distraction. Deep focus? That's not part of the plan. Then there's the watch list
cemetery. The digital graveyard of half-forgotten intentions. Hundreds of films, shows, podcasts,
all saved for later, all doomed to gather dust in the abyss of your device. The act of saving gives
you a little dopamine rush. Just enough to convince yourself you're being productive. But the truth?
You're collecting potential like a hoarder, never actually letting yourself experience anything.
The stress of watching something of giving it your attention is too much. So you don't.
Notifications are the real architects of this misery. Every buzz, every ping, every little alert
designed to yank you back into the cycle. Three minutes of peace? Impossible. Your phone won't
allow it. It keeps you in a state of perpetual interruption. A high alert irritability that passes
for engagement. Meanwhile, you're sitting on your couch, watching TV with your phone in hand,
splitting your attention like a bad magician. Neither experience is satisfying. You're bored twice
as hard for half the effort. And so you reach sensory saturation, the point where you're drowning in
data but starving for meaning. A miracle unfolds before you and you yawn. A masterpiece plays and you
scroll. You're connected to thousands, yet you've never felt lonelier. The digital world promised freedom.
Instead, it gave you a new kind of prison. One where the bars are made of light and the warden is an
algorithm. The subject in the residence log put it best. Screens for breakfast. Start the day with
app-based boredom and nothing else can compete. No real conversation. No actual adventure. No moment in
your life will ever match the potential of that endless feed. The bored man in the desert seeks
water. The bored man in the library seeks himself. The bored man on an app? He's just waiting for the
next refresh. And the worst part? You're not even bored anymore. You're just tired.